Aloha tout le monde de la belle Hawaï,
nous sommes ici sur l'île d'Oahu où
j'ai grandi
car vous le savez, Hawaï signifie tellement pour ma
famille et moi et les traditions de notre
Ohana ou aiinga comme on dit à Samoa ont été
façonnées par  ces îles incroyables, les
îles du Pacifique et leurs cultures
ont inspiré une histoire très spéciale que
vous connaissez tous très bien et cette histoire est un
roulement de tambour s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
nous sommes très excités et heureux d'annoncer
qu'une réimagination en direct de Moana
est dans le  ça marche Moana Grand-mère tala la
musique la danse te fiti puer le cochon le
village le magnifique océan puissant et
un de plus qu'est-ce que c'est les gars oh le vôtre vraiment hé hé
le poulet je plaisante hé hé
va être dedans mais bien sûr Maui
sera dans un deux  comme beaucoup d'entre vous ne
connaissent peut-être pas la brillante équipe de Disney
Animation, mes partenaires, nous avons trouvé tellement d'
inspiration de Maui dans le Mana et
la présence de mon défunt grand-père, le
légendaire grand chef Peter Maivia, dans lequel il
marchait illuminait la pièce l'
énergie les tatouages  les cheveux le corps quand
vous regardez un demi-dieu merci
désolé je suis pris dans le moment
pour que vous puissiez voir le timing parfait lorsque
le soleil se lève, à quel point l'
histoire est profonde pour moi parce que d'une certaine manière, quand
j'apporte  Maui dans la vie, je le fais dans l'
esprit de mon grand-père, donc euh, c'est
encore très tôt dans le processus, il y a encore
beaucoup de travail à faire, mais d'
ici là, il me reste encore une chose dont j'ai besoin
pour lancer ce voyage, hé les filles.
voulez-vous avoir cette chose spéciale
dont papa a besoin wow vous êtes
les filles de papa vous êtes si fortes
merci beaucoup les gars nous allons aller dans
l'océan oui
vous voulez de la glace les gars
ouais voyez donc Maui de papa
rit